when you say ambitious is there a dollar  amount no ambitious like driven wanting  something for himself and not just so if  he's making how old are you so you're 31  35 35 how old would you date  the oldest I would date yeah  probably 40. so if he's 40 and he still  makes 30  000 I don't know the conversion like 30  000 US Dollars which would be like 20  000 um 20 000 pounds would you be cool  with that he's 40 he said time to get  there  if he's if he's trying to get somewhere  and he's not just what if he gets  nowhere  whoa because I'd I'd sense that he's not  ambitious and it would put me off right  but I think like a lot of times it's  kind of disingenuous to guys because  girls will say there's no price but you  you have one in your head and there is a  price he there has to be working towards  that like towards it or there but if he  doesn't get there within a certain  amount of time your ghost you're gone